As shown in this graphic,
there are at least three key informatics challenges to
overcome in order to achieve a learning health care system.
First, providers must adopt digital records.
Second, no systems must be able to share data a characteristic called interoperability.
And third, that shared data must be aggregated,
analyzed, and presented in a clinically useful and timely manner.
Because of the federal government's high tech program,
that we'll discuss in the next lesson,
adoption is now a largely solved challenge.
Much of the excitement about fire rests on
its apparent ability to help overcome the interoperability challenge.
Fire apps, offer the prospect of solving the problem of
timely and useful presentation of the results of the new knowledge
gleaned from analysis of past care to busy physicians.
Here again, economics plays a key role.
If providers have an incentive to get it right and do that efficiently,
then they'll be interested in creating a learning health care system,
because they can more clearly see how they benefit from it.
Well, now consider one example,
when to discharge a patient after surgery.